let's go to your voicemails okay now I
want to prepare you for this there's a
long track record of someone in the
David Pakman show audience complaining
no matter what day we take off if we
take Columbus Day Off David why are you
taking off Columbus Day it represents
genocide of natives in the United States
and I always explain listen I think time
off is important for staff it makes more
sense to take time off when it's a
federal holiday because the audience is
smaller on those days anyway and then
sometimes we'll have people say well why
don't you take off a random other day
when we take off random days that aren't
holidays the audience goes crazy and
says how dare you take a random day off
so we take federal holidays off and we
took Thanksgiving off and there were a
number of people who were very angry
including this caller who called to 192
david p take a listen to this hey David
a longtime listener here
I just um normally a pretty hardcore
liberal here and I noticed you had taken
off for Thanksgiving and I just want to
say from liberal to local progress to
progress that's pretty shameful you know
Thanksgiving was the evil holiday if you
know it's pretty much glorifying there
is you know glorifying you know millions
of white males killing tens of millions
of Native Americans and it's just pretty
shameful you take the holiday off yeah I
don't think you're real progressive
maybe you should think about next time
I'm not taking a holiday off and then
doing a server somewhere Trump videos
about when he's going to go next and
trulia making you write all right
packing that's all bye okay
yeah listen what you're suggesting is
that taking Thanksgiving off is not
progressive but trying to make staff
work and miss family gatherings on
federal holidays would be progressive
give me a break dude
on the bonus show today we will be
talking about fears
about a post Mugabe Human Rights
crackdown in Zimbabwe we will talk about
Idaho dimming the lights for one of the
best night skies anywhere and a woman
shot by a hunter who thought she was a
deer all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show get access by
becoming a member of david pakman.com
slash membership or by making a patreon
pledge of at least five bucks a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
are back from Thanksgiving much to talk
about glad you're with us and we will
speak to you on the bonus show